und es gibt ja jemand mit dem es knallen
könnte und den hast du uns mitgebracht
heute lieber Bela ja das ist Robert
Habeck obwohl die einen so sanften
Anspruch und Auftritt hat dass man da
sich das gar nicht vorstellen kann dass
es mit dem Papa knallt obwohl in den
Hintergründen soll das anders sein und
war es fand ich bei Robert Habeck wer
hat in einem Gespräch mit einem ARD oder
für die ARD arbeiten Journalisten seine
Seele offenbart einen kleinen Seelen
Striptease gemacht wir sehen den Mann
Markus feldenkirchen hier auch im Bild
daneben Robert Habeck der hat die
nämlich begleitet werden Zwerghamster
rausgekommen ist dann ein Stunden
Porträt über den Mann der nun das
wichtigste Ministerium nach dem
Finanzministerium vor dem Kanzleramt für
das Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
Ministerium robert hat mir nicht und in
diesem Stück sagt er nachts um zwei
irgendwann before ich bei das alles ist
als alle ihn hassen werden dass er
natürlich ganz stark unter Kritik zu
sein wird wenn er dann irgendwann in der
Regierung ist und zu Hause sieht auch
furchtbar aus die Spüle ist voll
ungewaschen wie seit Tagen schon den
Müll nicht rausgebracht und überhaupt
heute an dem Tage an den das aufgenommen
wurde hat er Müsli nur mit Wasser
gegessen und nicht mit Milch weil auch
die nicht mehr Maus war noch nicht mal
mehr habe mich mimimimimi so klingt das
für mich
Robert Habeck wird das anspruchsvollste
Ministerium neben den beiden anderen
Ämtern die ist in Deutschland gibt führt
er hat eine riesen
Transformationsprozess Vorsicht da muss
gucken dass die Umstellung für die
Wirtschaft nicht zu hart werden und auch
nicht für die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher zu teuer muss ich abstimmen
mit den Grünen Fraktion mit der Fraktion
mit dem Koalitionspartner wird nach
Brüssel reisen müssen den die 7 in
dieses Jahr in Deutschland stattfindet
vorbereitet und und und 24 Stunden sind
dann nicht genug es gibt einen schönen
Spruch dafür der kommt von Harry S
Truman für can't stand the heat get out
of the kitchen oder wie Gerd Schröder im
frei übersetzen gesagt hat Films in der
Küche zu heiß ist der sollte nicht Koch
werden ich hoffe dass Robert Habeck dies
auch für Herd
wieder Adresse in der gewisser Weise
durchaus komisch gewesen wie du das
ganze vorgetragen hast dabei wissen wir
dass ich dieses Land ja alles andere als
in einer komischen Situation befindet im
du hast habe ich auch vollkommen zu
Recht gesagt Robert Habeck hat nach Olaf
Scholz nach Christian hinter und man
muss sagen auch nach Lauterbach nach
Calau Tabak eins der zentralen
Ministerien die erführen muss das
Wirtschafts und Klima Ministerium aber
ich glaube Robert habe in der Tat muss
aufpassen dass er als politischer Star
hier in Berlin nicht auch ziemlich
schnell verglüht denn natürlich hat der
Multi Probleme zu Händen da gibt es
einmal seine Partei auf die er wie ein
Pulverfass nach dem Machtkampf
eigentlich jetzt sich geriert derzeit
noch der ganze Dampf unterm enddeckel
gehalten aber wir wissen auch von Toni
Hofreiter und Katrin Göring-Eckardt da
brodelt es ganz gewaltig also vor allem
der Hundi Flüge ist auf der Zinne dann
haben dass mich das Ministerium das
Wirtschaftsministerium ein Uhr gelb
schwarzes muss man sagen die heißen
einen grünen Minister sicherlich und ich
übertreibe es Achtung Ironie mit offenen
Armen willkommen vor allem wenn er sagt
und ich stehe jetzt mal alles hier auf
den Kopf und dann gibt es natürlich auch
noch die Ampel das ist ja ganz klar es
gibt keine FTP ist gibt ein
Finanzminister Christian Lindner der im
Zweifel auch sagen mit dir mein lieber
Robert wenn die beiden Duden sicher dass
es wieder ganz toll was du mir alles
möchtest aber dafür ist er kein Geld R&B
mache ich das als Parteichef der FDP gar
nicht mit deswegen glaube ich Robert
Habeck wäre gut beraten jetzt weniger
Selbstbespiegelung zu tun ans Werk zu
gehen und ich glaube er wird ein Stern
sein der ist sehr sehr schwer hat so
weiter zu strahlen wie es der 2 macht
das Verhältnis zwischen Christian
Lindner und Robert Habeck soll er gar
nicht mehr so gut sein wie es mal war
seit den Koalitionsverhandlungen sollst
ja auch ordentlich geknallt haben
zwischen den beiden wegen dem
Finanzministerium erhoben habe ich
wusste ja gar nicht richtig was er
eigentlich will auch das glaube ich ein.
Er wollte Klima Minister werden dann
wollt er zwischendurch mal Innenminister
wären am liebsten wäre eine
Finanzminister geworden also Robert
Habeck ich kenne ihn jetzt sehr stark
und Robert Habeck und das ist
interessant dass es einem grünen
offenbar dann doch eher um den eigenen
Job die eigene macht den Ei Dienstwagen
geht und doch gar nicht so und ich
dachte immer gerade den Grünen geht um
Nachhaltigkeit glaube ich dass ein so
weit sollten wir nicht gehen ich glaube
schon dass Robert habe ich auch uns
eingelangt geht also er wäre ich glaube
nicht dass er versessen ist auf
Dienstwagen und soweit es ist Karin
glaube ziemlich egal aber ich glaube
schon das ist nur um das Amt schon das
Amt die sind nicht egal ich glaube aber
auch wenn du mir
dabei
jemand der Politiker ist durch und durch
und ich weiß dass das nicht so gesehen
wird in Berlin
mit dem Fahrrad sondern jeder wird er
mit dem fahrrad
gute Nacht mein Schatz Demirci mir
konsequent oder muss ich sagen wann die
anderen Minister Dienstwagen
lassen gesperrt weil die Bürger nicht
mehr durch fahren sollen und dann sagen
Minister die einen kurzen Weg
zurückzulegen haben von den Grünen und
dann auch noch Ressorts die Umwelt neu
besetzen die sagen dann nachher wir
lassen uns mit dem Auto hinfahren
weil viele das nicht sehen viele glauben
Politik ist immer das Gleiche ob du das
als Kommunalpolitiker oder soll man es
immer nur eine andere Liga das hat man
völlig falsches denken es ist jeweils
eine andere Sportart mit anderen Regeln
mehr Körperlichkeit weniger
Körperlichkeit und das wird für für
Robert habe glaube ich noch ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt sein in dieser sehr
harten Bundespolitik anzukommen da haben
Leute die Olaf Scholz und Christian
Lindner natürlich große Vorteil das
heißt aber noch lange nicht dass jemand
wie Robert Habeck nicht genau das lernt
ja es ist er sich ein Teil seiner ja
dessen was viele Menschen begeistert an
robert habe ich die Möglichkeit zu
reflektieren über sich selbst zu sich
selbst auch in Frage zu stellen aber er
wird keine Zeit mehr haben für sich wenn
wir beim 100 Tagen bei den 100 Tagen
noch nicht mal innerhalb dieser 100
Tagen und da muss er eine andere
Wahrnehmung haben auch von sich und
jemand der sich ständig selbst infrage
stellt der ist da nicht mehr tatsächlich
so en vogue auch nicht mehr so geliebt
sondern da erwartet man jemanden der
sein Haus im Griff hat schöne Dinge
umsetzt und auch nachher voll
verrückt
rheingrün Minister diskutiert haben kann
man immer wieder ein Muster sehen
nämlich dass die Grünen häufig auch an
ihre eigenen Glaubwürdigkeit scheitern
so die Grünen predigen ja ganz oft
Wasser für ganz viele Teile der
Bevölkerung sagen die Bevölkerung soll
sich einschränken die sollen teilweise
weniger heizen die sollen auf aufs Auto
achten dass sie nicht zu viel Autofahren
die soll nicht zu viel fliegen sondern
kommt raus naja da fliegen viele grüne
Politiker irgendwo mal hin meistens dann
auch in der relativ guten Klasse dann
ergibt grün Politiker die sich eben mit
dem Auto auch manchmal ein Kilometer
fahren lassen meiner sogar das Auto ganz
kurz vorher noch abstellen und sich gab
ja auch mal Anfall dann kurz vor noch
ein Fahrrad geben lassen um demonstrativ
vor den Kameras mit dem Fahrrad auf die
Tauchtiefe sobron das
Wein trinken ja das ist mir zu pauschal
so stimmt das auch nicht ich glaube bei
vielen Gründen kann man tatsächlich
unterstellen und positiv unterstellen
dass sie das was sie ausstrahlen das was
sie glauben ihre politischen Beweggründe
auch tatsächlich zu Politik machen
wollen nicht eben grün der ein
Dienstwagen benutzt sollte man
unterstellen dass er damit
Privilegien in Anspruch nimmt dir sonst
nie hätte wieder aber ich glaube wir
sollten auch den Anspruch haben auch aus
Sicherheitsgründen und aus anderen
Gründen aus Zeitgründen Zugriff zu haben
auf diese Wagen selbst diese Fahrer
waren immer war einfach eine Show und
ich waren sie deplaziert und deswegen
waren halt doch ein Unterschied
Christian Lindner gönne ich das von
Herzen weil der ist Bekenner Porsche Fan
der sagt jetzt auch nicht der
Bevölkerung hier dürft kein Auto mehr
fahren und ich bin so seine einzige der
das darf aber wenn die Grünen der
Pflegekraft die morgens um sechs uhr mit
der Schicht im Krankenhaus beginnt sagt
nee nimmt man jetzt die Uhr der S-Bahn
oder nehmt das Fahrrad im Winter
man sich dann eine ganz kurze Strecke
hellichten Tag chauffieren lässt dann
finde ich ist das schon ein
glaubwürdiger schwarz-weiß und
entspricht euch auch nicht